c'est le demi de coin j'ai une situation
tu as 85 secondes quelqu'un a essayé de
me tuer un appel je suis juste une ambulance j'ai
seulement fait trois semaines à la ferme ouais
ouais je dois aller à Moscou pourquoi tu ne
veux pas que je vienne  Je travaillerai
tout le temps que les Américains aiment se considérer
comme réalisateur, mais cela vous aide
ce qui est juste grossier peut-être que vous touchez juste,
parlez-moi de votre scénario très effrayant
, ça va être un anéantissement, nous
ne le verrons jamais venir alors je '  je suis ici tu
m'as menti pendant trois ans tout le monde veut
bien sûr pas toi Je peux avoir une
minute s'il te plait non c'est de la géopolitique pas une
thérapie de couple j'allais ici
parfois les plus proches de nous sont
ceux à qui nous devrions faire confiance le bail
il y a  un scénario très réel dont nous ne
sortons pas vivants où elle pense
que c'est du game jack